and and the the title of the your talk
is the time poverty amidst digital
abundance so is time party poverty is
that is that mostly a perceptual thing I
mean is that I don't know how much that
is actually a term of art or just a coin
edge of yours but you know is is it more
would you say a trick we're playing on
ourselves or is it also as you're just
saying sort of different populations
that are having different channels
because certainly the person is working
three jobs has a different kind of time
poverty than the person who just has
that calendar but I mean I think here
particularly what's very strong is the
kind of culture of busyness I mean I was
lucky enough to do a radio interview
with William Gibson once on BBC radio
when his most recent book had come out
it was a kind of couple of years ago you
know the science fiction writer and he
said to me you know actually saying
you're incredibly busy now is just
saying you're incredibly rich but that's
you know that that's the kind of
equivalent now and I mean I've had
people say to me at some of my talks I
mean you know colleague of mine in
Cambridge actually I've known for years
said to me you know if I go back to my
office now and there are no emails I'll
feel like a loser I feel like a failure
you know but this is so much a measure
of kind of our sense of kind of self and
who we are and our importance and our
status that it's very hard to
deconstruct you know that it's that
culture actually of you know and
anything I have to say that when I you
know first came to America and I'm like
30 years ago I have to say when I was
you know I think I my first job was in
Edinburgh I remember sort of various
people said to me you know when you get
to America all those American academics
they're all gonna tell you that they're
incredibly busy you've just got to be
prepared for this you know that this is
part of that you know it's just part of
the you know what's culturally valued I
think and that I think makes leisure
such an undervalued activity
[Music]